what advice would you give to um to
people looking to start learning Jiu
Jitsu given how busy you are given where
you are in life that you were able to do
this you're able to train you're able to
compete and get uh to learn something
from this interesting art
why'd you think you have to be willing
to
[Music]
um
to just get beaten up a lot yeah I mean
but but I mean over time I think that
there's there's a flow to all these
things and there's um
you know
one of the
one of I don't know my experiences that
I think kind of transcends you know
running a company in the different
different activities that I like doing
or I I really believe that like if
you're going to accomplish whatever
anything a lot of it is just being
willing to push through right and having
the grit and determination to to to push
through difficult situations
um I think for a lot of people that
um that ends up being sort of a
Difference Maker between the people you
know who who kind of get the most done
and not I mean there's all these
questions about like
um you know how how many days people
want to work and things like that I
think almost all the people who like
start successful companies or things
like that are just are working extremely
hard but I think one of the things that
you learn both by doing this over time
or you know very acutely with things
like Jiu Jitsu or surfing is um
you can't push through everything
and
I think that that's
you you learn this stuff very acutely
run doing sports compared to running a
company because running a company the
cycle times are so long right it's like
you start a project and then you know
it's like months later or you know if
you're building Hardware it could be
years later before you're actually
getting feedback and able to you know
make the next set of decisions for the
next version of the thing that you're
doing whereas you one of the things that
I just think is mentally so nice about
these very high turnaround
conditioning Sports things like that is
you get feedback very quickly right it's
like okay like I I don't counter
something correctly you get punched in
the face right so not in Jiu Jitsu you
know you don't get punched in Jiu Jitsu
but an MMA
um there are all these analogies between
all these things that I think actually
hold that are that are like
important life lessons right it's like
okay you're surfing a wave it's like
you know sometimes you're like you can't
go in the other direction on it right
it's like there are limits to kind of
what you know it's like foil you can you
can pump the foil and and push pretty
hard in a bunch of directions but like
yeah you you know it's at some level
like the momentum against you is is
strong enough you're that's not going to
work and and I do think that
um that's sort of a a humbling but also
an important lesson for I think people
who are running things or building
things it's like yeah you you um you
know a lot of the game is just being
able to kind of push and and and and
work through complicated things but you
also need to kind of have enough of an
understanding like which things you just
can't push through and where where um
um the Finesse is more important yeah
what are your Jiu Jitsu life lessons
well I think you did it
you made it sound so simple
and we're so eloquent that it's easy to
miss
but basically being okay and accepting
the wisdom and the joy in the uh getting
your ass kicked
in the full range of what that means I
think that's a big gift of the being
humbled
somehow being humbled especially
physically opens your mind to the the
full process of learning what it means
to learn which is being willing to suck
at something I think Jiu Jitsu is just
very repetitively efficiently humbles
you over and over and over and over to
where you can carry that lessons to
places where you don't get humbled as
much whether it's research or running a
company or building stuff the the cycle
is longer and you just so you can just
get humbled in a period of an hour over
and over and over and over especially
when you're a beginner you'll have a
little person
just you know somebody much smarter than
you just kick your ass uh repeatedly uh
definitively where there's no argument
oh yeah and then you you literally tap
because if you don't tap you're going to
die so this is an agreement
you could have killed me just now but
we're friends so you were going to agree
that you're not going to and that kind
of humbling process it just does
something to your psyche to Your Ego
that puts it in its proper context to
realize that you know everything
in this life is like a journey from
sucking
through a hard process of improving or
rigorously day after day after day after
day any kind of success requires hard
work
um yeah it's just some more than a lot
of sports I would say because I've done
a lot of them it really teaches you that
and you made it sound so simple like I'm
almost you know it's it's okay it's part
of the process you just get humble get
yourself I've just failed and been
embarrassed so many times in my life
that like you know I'm I'm it's a core
competence of this it's a core
competence well yes and there's a deep
truth to that being able to and you said
it in the very beginning which is that's
the thing that stops US especially as
you get older especially as you develop
expertise in certain areas the
not being willing to be a beginner in a
new area yeah uh that because that's
where the growth happens is being
willing to be a beginner being willing
to be embarrassed saying something
stupid doing something stupid
um a lot of us that get good at one
thing we want to show that off and it
sucks
uh being a beginner but it's where
growth happens